Oi bom dia pessoal prazer estar aqui com
vocês e que trazer né esse assunto que
para a gente foi bem importante a uma
hora atrás a gente conversava assim
fazia a palestras em alguns lugares EA
que a gente colocava uma foto de alguém
na Síria né a gente colocar agora ele já
tem fotos brasileiras para colocar aqui
são todas as fotos que a gente quê que a
gente acompanhou muito bem né na
jornadas de junho e isso Traz essa essa
percepção acho que de né de muitos de
nós de que a política não serve mais
aquilo que quer o nosso objetivo né
gente se organiza como sociedade para
que as coisas possam funcionar melhor né
que a gente possa ter aí um uma Tem
coisas que a gente só pode consumir
coletivamente né essas coisas são por
exemplo segurança por exemplo saneamento
por exemplo próprio sistema de saúde né
eu digo que a gente possa atendido
aumente com sucesso então é muito bom a
gente poder estar em sociedade poder
desenvolver ações que que nos fortaleçam
dessa forma eu acho que eu hoje a gente
tem a percepção de que o essa nossa
organização né que a esse sub
consubstanciado nos governos poderia
estar sendo muito mais poderia tratar
oferecendo pra gente muito mais e a
gente tem um palpite sobre Por que que a
gente tem essa insatisfação nesse
momento aqui não sei se vocês vão
conseguir ler então bem mas eu trouxe
para mostrar os alguns números né de no
Brasil quais são os profissionais mais
valorizados né tu lá em cima a gente tem
com noventa e tantos por cento os
bombeiros né são os mais valorizados os
professores né Isso é bom aqui para o
nosso caso para médicos pilotos farão a
ser
o teste a gente vem descendo né aqui no
meio fazendeiros artesãos vendedores de
varejo aqui já com cinquenta por cento
ele tem pastores e padres atletas
funcionários públicos estão ali com -50%
um pouco apresentador de TV também puxar
setor bancário daqui com pouco mais de
40 a gente tem os policiais advogados
com 40 a gente de seguro então tô mal eu
não sei se esquece algo a gente de
seguro Então estou bem
Oi e aí prefeitos com quatorze por cento
e políticos em geral com seis por cento
entre si um retrato esse grupo faz isso
no mundo inteiro né e ele sempre
atualizam isso esse não esse é o número
só melhor caso que eu trouxe para trazer
para não é para exemplificar isso que a
gente tá tá fazendo mais esse número eu
não tenho mudado a gente vai
acompanhando isso né mas não muda
realmente a gente não gosta não gosta
dos políticos né
O que é a a internet Léo concepção de
que a internet muda tudo no nosso jeito
de ser né o assunto que tá mais todo
mundo falando hoje são os aplicativos de
táxi né ou então esse o Waze que que a
gente tem fim aperta lá lá em Perdizes e
ele traz a gente aqui na UFABC dizendo
exatamente hora que a gente vai chegar a
gente chega na hora Prefeito ainda assim
ajudando os outros se tiver qualquer
coisa a gente ainda ajuda os outros
fazendo isso é isso mudou totalmente a
forma como a gente dirige mudou a forma
com a gente pega táxi mudou a forma como
a gente compra presente como a gente
consome música como a gente consome
notícia e o quanto isso poderia mudar a
política né Então a nossa aposta é muito
nesse sentido então é e a gente acredita
muito que essa mudança ela vai acontecer
ela tem condições de acontecer melhor do
que em qualquer outro lugar no Brasil
que
eu acho que acredita que o Brasil ele
ele junta o melhor das duas
pré-condições fundamentais para que isso
possa acontecer dessa forma bem lugar a
gente tem muita questão para resolver a
gente tem muito problema no Brasil né
então se eu for para a Dinamarca por
exemplo ele estava conversando com a
conversando com uma amiga hoje de manhã
e que tava dizendo que tava fazendo um
trabalho de dados abertos para cima de
transporte com uma outra pessoa que era
aqui da Suíça da Bélgica e tal daí vamos
começar a baixar os dados né ba dados
públicos sobre transporte aí daí nesse
daí ele eles tinham acesso a tudo lá na
Bélgica estão todos os dados não sei se
era Bélgica exatamente e aqui no Brasil
a gente não tinha esses dados difícil né
puxava tentar achar um pouco aqui um
pouco ali tão né dizendo Ela perguntou
para amiga né tudo o que que você tá
fazendo esse trabalho aqui se vocês têm
tudo já pronto lá né aí a amiga dela
disse que é
e se preocupar muito porque sabe a gente
tava um problema lá que as empresas de
transporte por elas não estão falando
pra gente Quais são os valores da
remuneração doce osso
uma das empresas de transporte então
quer dizer é isso tem tudo a ver Clara
muito importante é que a gente possa
fazer mas assim acho que não é não tá no
topo da da nossa prioridade saber qual é
a remuneração dos dirigentes das
empresas de transporte público é de que
o ônibus passa né seja bom né seja
confortável né que não seja caro Enfim
então a gente está em outro lugar então
fazer o Brasil tem muita coisa para
gente poder resolver e ao mesmo tempo o
Brasil tem muita capacidade então aqui a
gente vê por exemplo a gente meu
trabalho sensacional que foi apresentado
aqui antes quer dizer está acontecendo
no Brasil isso é uma tecnologia de ponta
sendo desenvolvido a gente tem muita
gente boa no Brasil e a gente também tem
muito interessante é muito aberto eu
tinha muito permeável ao que é digital
que eletrônica rede social a gente gosta
de sente gosta de se relacionar e tudo
mais então mais do que em qualquer outro
lugar e também no também sou lugares
onde a democracia já tá muito mais
consolidada
a festa tem processo de consolidação é
como a gente considera é o Brasil estava
seja um lugar onde isso vai acontecer e
onde a gente quer chegar a gente tem a
percepção de que o que a gente puder
chegar em um por cento da população e
isso é uma uma é um número mágico
obviamente mas gente imagina aqui um por
cento da população ao que a gente
precisa para que a gente desencadeia um
assunto epidêmica em direção a esse novo
novo jeito de lidar com a política e com
tudo mais né que é uma política que seja
feita a partir das diferentes vozes que
a gente tem né quiser hoje um político
não é ele não precisa mais ter boas
ideias e dizer já sei vou fazer uma
pesquisa de mercado e vou descobrir o
que as pessoas estão tão querendo né eu
vou fazer e depois eu vejo na eleição se
o pessoal gostou mesmo daquilo que eu
fiz hoje a gente tem Facebook tenho
Claro não o nosso nossa própria
plataforma digital mas a gente tem
Twitter a gente tem
as formas de raspar esses dados lei
esses dados entendeu que a população de
fato tá pedindo tá querendo que seja
feito né Tem plataformas de petição
pública e tudo mais então tudo isso
permitiria que os políticos hoje
pudessem conhecer muito mais o melhor e
com detalhe exatamente o que que eles
precisam fazer para serem bons
representantes da de todo mundo que eles
estão ali na eventualmente representando
então a gente imagina que chegar em um
por cento seria o número o número
necessário para que pudesse aí mudar
para esse novo paradigma
quem é e a gente começou esse trabalhos
envolvendo o vocabulário da participação
social na América Latina Então a partir
das ontologia possível que todo mundo
que trabalha com participação social
possa fazer uma leitura dos seus dados
de uma forma semelhante Essa é a gente
possa né é cometidos aqui não só
vincular é associar a base de dados que
existe Eu tenho um site que trabalha com
participação social e vocês aqui podem
ter muitas outras iniciativas a gente
vai poder somar essas bases de dados e
poder fazer uma leitura agregada de
todos esses resultados né que não
importa o que tem na minha iniciativa né
na minha iniciativa ela ela é privada né
velho é minha né Além de que tenha um
interesse público ela Ela é só minha né
o que importa na participação social e o
que é nosso Então se todas as nossas
bases podem ser somadas aí sim a gente
começa a falar mais do nosso mesmo né e
modelar conhecimento A partir dessa
inteligência
Oi e aí no futuro poder fazer
visualizações desses dados e poder fazer
mashup desses dados e